I've been on a couple of times I've  known Myron for a few years and like  when you're there I mean I I sort of  fundamentally disagree that they're  disrespectful to the women because  actually they they will you they will  always give everyone an opportunity to  come in yes you know um and and if a  male guest actually is is talking too  much something they'll they'll calm them  don't say no let her come in and you and  even when you see them before the  program and they're interacting with the  women and everything he's very very  respectful there's no sort of you know  because they are either pop for anything  else they know that these women are kind  of make what part of what's making the  show so popular they would fundamentally  disagree that they are in any way being  sort of like deliberately derogatory  towards the women I mean what's being  displayed may appear derogatory but  that's often because of the way the  women are behaving